- [Seth] Yeah.
- You got me drunk on
your late night show,
so it's only fair we
day-drink on my daytime show.
- Great.
- So, get ready, Meyers!
(crowd cheering)
Get ready!
- I'm very excited.
- Okay, drinks are coming in.
Each drink is themed to a
different area of your life.
- Oh. That's so exciting.
- So first up, I know,
you had specialty drinks.
We only prefer the best here as well.
- First up we've got the Lucky
Seven in honor of the seventh
season of Late Night with Seth Meyers.
- [Seth] Oh my God, how 'bout that?
(crowd cheering)
Thank you.
- It's got coffee liquor
for those late nights.
- Okay.
- 'Cause we all need caffeine.
A shot of vodka to help you
get through political jokes.
- [Seth] Okay.
- 'Cause there's just
so much potential there.
There's so much material to pull from.
- Absolutely.
Might need two shots.
- Yeah.
Gold flakes for the glitzy
Hollywood actors on your show.
- [Seth] All right.
- And it's on the rocks since
you tape a 30 Rock, get it?
- [Seth] Okay, great.
- Okay.
- [Seth] Cheers, here we go.
- Here we go. (clapping)
Paper straws, save the turtles.
(crowd cheering)
- You don't have to drink the whole thing!
- I don't?
- Wait!
I was like, "Don't challenge me, Meyers!"
- Oh okay, got it.
- 'Cause I'm so competitive,
and I don't want to go home hammered.
- This is a real milky drink.
- I know, I think might get an upset tummy
from that one, yeah.
- [Kelly] Mm-hmm, it's great.
- Aside from me, who was your
most memorable... Get it.
Oh, if you would have got...
okay, now I have to try it.
- All right, come on.
- I told you I'm competitive.
Okay, wait.
Or wait, you throw it and
I'll try and catch it.
- You think that's a better idea?
- Oh shoot!
Yes, okay, are you ready?
It's way back there! (crowd yelling)
It's way back there!
- Oh!
- You're like, here, the zone, the zone.
Oh! (crowd yelling)
No wait, I got it.
I can't get it. (crowd laughing)
- How do you think in general...?
- I can't get it.
I love it when we get together,
we just do like fraternity games.
- Yeah, I was gonna say,
do the interviews go off
the rails this quickly?
- No.
Well yes.
- Okay, good.
- [Kelly] Sometimes, yes.
- All right, good.
- It's going how it usually does.